j'aimerais
que commencer
en mentionnant
que
j'utilise une technique de
respiration pour contrôler
le bégaiement
alors j'espère que vous aimez le ce
suspense
aller
ou ne pas parler
pendant que je grandissais
au liban avec un
bégaiement très prononcé
j'ai fait le choix de
ne pas parler
pour quoi
[Musique]
lancé dans le monde
alors que
que je pouvais me
cacher
dans le cocon
et isolant
mais réconfortant de mon silence
j'ai évité la parole
autant que je
je
je le pouvais
et quand je ne le peux pouvait pas
je ressentais une honte
de l'embarras
et de la queue colère
pour quoi moi
je me détestais
je détestais il le fait de devoir être
si différents
tout le temps
je
détestais au
[Musique]
moulin capacité de
lire les mots
pour
traduire mes pensées mes sentiments et
et mes émotions
un jour j'étais dans
une fête
une universitaire ici à montréal à l'âge
de 19 ans
je je
je rencontre quelqu'un et
on s'entend très bien
on
osseux au se tient la main
et est ensuite elle me demande
comment tu t'appelles
mau mau
mau
au nom
était le mot que
je
j'avais le plus de mal à prononcer
alors je réponds et
et alors que
je m'efforce à lui dire qui je suis
et me lâche la main et elle s'en va
waze est
adhérente cei
parler cet acte 6 et
élémentaires que tout le monde feu
faisait si facilement
et est une
une une mission impossible pour moi
j'en avais assez
quelque chose devait changer
[Musique]
robert frost à a dit une fois
la meilleure façon de s'en sortir
c'est de faire la traversée
pour moi cela signifiait que la seule
façon
pour surmonter mon bégaiement et toute
la peur et la douleur que qui
l'accompagnait
ce serait en faisant à
plusieurs reprises
il
la chose que je craignais le plus
parler
premièrement j'ai appris cette technique
de respiration pour
contrôler nos bégaiement et pour la
première fois dans ma vie
j'ai ressenti un certain contrôle sur ce
cauchemar
au so if
he
looks
fraudeurs
ensuite j'ai rejoint
[Musique]
toastmasters pour surmonter la peur du
discours en public et
que croyez moi c'était terrifiant au
haut au début
d'ailleurs ma
ma main deuxième année
d'université à montréal j'ai supplié les
professeurs de me
dispenser de toutes mes présentations
aux dernières
années par contre j'ai rejoint le club
de débats
et j'ai réalisé que ce que je dis
importe beaucoup plus que la vitesse
avec laquelle je je le dis
en
2017 j'ai gagné plusieurs concours
de discours en public
recevant le prix de le l'orateur
inspirant de l'année
ce ce que
j'osais il y a cinq ans ou ou même dix
ans
n'aurait jamais cru
c'est dernière que quelques années j'ai
aussi fait du
stand up et jeu et je me suis produit
dans trois continents
et donc quatre langues
en fait je je bégaie dans
six langues différents
jeux je bégaie en français as the
english
de blanc a lavé
de tamure haut et
et un espagnol à l'ogive hagard et un
portugais
yves yamaska aussi les
9000 kg ou au rwanda
3 armin
hahne au
ayem n'entrerez le nom doit keep up with
the kardashians
g j'ai
constamment
passer par des hauts et des bas
si vous
passez par des hauts
et
les bas lever la main s'il vous plaît
j'ai constamment
passer par ça mais à chaque fois
que
que les émotions négatives dupont
passé refaisait surface
g
je m'y attaquer
en me rendant au centre commercial
où je donnais le défi de parler avec 101
connu chaque semaine
cet exercice et été
difficile épuisant et très
inconfortable
mais c'était comme exposant à la source
de mes peurs que j'ai pas revenue et que
je
parviens à les surmonter
tous les jours
j'affronte moon obstacle
un mot
après l'autre
et alors que mon bégaiement est visible
le vôtre
peut ne pas l'être
autant
si vous avez déjà permis à la peur de
2,2
vous vous vous empêcher de faire quelque
chose que vous voulez faire
s'il vous plaît lever la main
ok
je m'excuse mais chaque
personne ici bégué
à sa façon
quand vous êtes en cours ou dans une
réunion
et que vous vous voulez peut participer
mais vous restez
ce silencieux
ça
c'est votre bégaiement
quand vous êtes dans une conférence que
comme celle ci et que vous voulez
rencontrer quelqu'un de nouveau
mais a peur du rejet
vous vous empêche de dire bonjour
ça c'est votre bégaiement
à chaque fois que nous ce succombons à
notre bégaiement
nous retrait si son
neveu notre destin
on nous prive en d'innombrables
possibilités
par contre quand on fait face à la peur
est que qu'on apprend à se
supporter l'inconfort
notre
potentiel croît
d'une manière est
exponentielle
et nous devenons veut véritablement
les artisans
de notre destin
j'aimerais que conclure
avec une de mes ces
citations préférées
du philosophe
roumi
pourquoi restez-vous en prison
alors que que que la porte est si grande
ouverte
je suis resté dans une prison que je me
suis imposé mains moi même
la prison de mont finances
quel est votre prison
et quand
allez-vous vous échapper
me
merci
[Applaudissements]